[MUSIC PLAYING]
THORSTEN KURTH: Hello, and thank
you, everybody, for attending
the afternoon sessions.
My name is Thorsten Kurth.
And I'm an application
performance specialist
at NERSC.
And my day-to-day
work is helping
scientists optimize their codes
for contemporary supercomputer
systems.
Today I'm going to talk
about a project I care about
because it combines three
different things I'm
excited about.
This is big computers,
so exascale.
It's deep learning.
And it's climate
change because it
will affect everybody, every
one of us sooner or later.
So this is a team effort.
And I want to thank, at
this point, everybody
in this collaborative effort
between NERSC, Nvidia, UC
Berkeley, and Oak Ridge
for making this a success.
So thank you at this point.
So I want to talk about our
extreme weather phenomena.
So why are they important?
They're important
because they can
incur a lot of damage
and loss of life
and these kind of things.
For example, 2017, the
damage to the US economy
was about 200 billion for
the combined extreme weather
events.
So these can be hurricanes,
or tropical cyclones,
and, for example,
atmospheric rivers
because they can cause heavy
flooding and major disruption.
So we won't understand
these events better.
But what a typical climate data
analysis is-- so for example,
you have these
simulations, which
look into the future
up to 100 years.
You run different
models and get these.
So on your left, you see the
output of the simulations.
And they basically contain
14 million observables
for a three-hour interval.
And then you have like
100 years worth of that.
And what people usually do when
you look at the IPCC report,
for example, or in
popular magazines,
they boil it down to
a couple of numbers.
For example, temperature
rise, sea level rise,
these kind of things.
However, if the temperature
increases by one degrees
or two, that matters.
But it might not
matter to you if you
live in the middle
of the Sahara, right?
It might matter to
you, though, if you
are in different regions of the
globe-- and also the sea level
rise.
So the thing is
now, what you want
to do is you want to have a
geospatial analysis of climate
change.
So how does climate
change impact your life
where you live?
So we want to
answer things like,
will there be more
hurricanes, for example?
And if yes, will
they be more intense?
Will they make more landfalls?
If they stay over the
sea, it's usually not
as bad as when they
hit the coastline.
And for atmospheric
rivers, for example,
50% of all rain in California
is due to atmospheric rivers.
So it's an important
question to ask
if we will get more water,
like more rain, due to this.
And you, for example,
think about forest fires,
like the campfire last year
we had in the Bay Area.
We had a hard time
breathing for two weeks.
It's really a question if you
get more or fewer of these.
And this is really dependent
on these atmospheric rivers,
for example.
So insurance industry-- for
example, water planners--
a lot of different
people need to know
what they need to get up for.
So how can we do this?
So we have this high
fidelity climate simulations.
And what we, for
example, can start with--
picking out the these events.
For example, hurricanes
and atmospheric rivers.
Let's start with these.
And image segmentation
techniques
can offer pixel-level
resolution.
So they can do a
per-pixel classification
to pick these events out
and then correlate them
geospatially with the
underlying region, for example.
And deep learning, as you know,
is very successful in here
because, for example, the whole
autonomous driving industry
is doing that day in, day out.
And there's a lot of research
going on in this direction.
So the data set we have
is of 20 terabytes.
So we have like 400
terabyte in storage.
But for this work, we
use 20 terabytes of it.
And what I call an image
here is more like a tensor.
It's a three-dimensional tensor
of this 1152 times 768 times
16.
And the channels are not RGB.
They present observables
like wind speed,
temperature, pressure,
for different altitudes,
and these kind of things.
So they're general observables.
We have free classes.
So background, which is not
nothing interesting going on.
Then the tropical
cyclones, or hurricanes,
and the atmospheric rivers.
Fortunately, these events
are still rare in the future.
So 95% of the pixels
are background,
which is good for us.
But it's harder to
train a model on that
because of this high imbalance.
And another thing which makes
it different from the classical,
let's say, streets
in segmentation
is that all the
objects here are--
so first, there's a lot of stuff
going on in the background.
It's not static or slow moving.
And also the objects
themselves, they change rapidly
in size and shape, right?
So even when you look at this
image, this satellite image
from the hurricane, even as an
expert, you don't know actually
where you want to say, like
where this hurricane starts
or ends, right?
So the labels are pretty fuzzy.
So talking about that,
how did we get those?
Of course, the best would be
using human annotated labels.
But for that data, we didn't
have that at the time.
We are currently
working on that, though.
So for this effort, we use
some algorithmic labeling,
which is an old school
approach in the sense
that it's basically based
on future engineering
together with some thresholding
to get the binary masks.
One can say, OK, why don't
you do the predictions
with these algorithms, then?
Because you have a lot of
shortcomings in this algorithm.
So they are regional dependent.
Even for different thresholds
get vastly different labels.
So however, they're
still good enough
to fit in a network with it.
And it can pick up
better features,
as I will show you later.
So for image segmentation
architecture,
we picked DeepLab
version 3+ variant.
So it was developed by Google.
And basically, it
has an-- as all
these segmentation network
has an encoder, which
extracts the features.
And the decoder part, which
then makes the predictions
and the skip
connections in order
to feed the features
at different levels
from the encoder
stage into the decoder
to improve the
prediction quality.
So the original DeepLab had
a [INAUDIBLE] interpolation
as a decoder.
And we replaced this with a
fully deconvolution decoder.
I think the original choice
was made for training reasons
because it's easier to train
the [INAUDIBLE] interpolater
because it doesn't
have a lot of weights.
So our model has 44.7
million parameters.
And the training cost
for a single step
on a single sample--
so forward, backward--
is 14.4 teraflop,
which is 14.4 times 10 to the
12 floating point operations.
And on a modern GPU,
like this Nvidia V100,
you can only fit two
batches in half precision
or one in single
precision on the GPU.
So what you need to do is you
need to train it in parallel.
And we took a purely data
parallel approach here.
So we used Horovod for this.
So Horovod is
basically a framework
which hooks into the TensorFlow
graph in synchronous fashion.
And reduces tensors
across all the workers
as they are ready to be reduced.
It does this using MPI.
So it provides MPI
callback function.
MPI is Message
Passing Interface.
It's a very common framework
for exchanging messages
between different-- in
a distributed memory
system such as HPC systems.
The good thing is that since
a lot of people in HPC use it,
it's very highly
optimized usually
for these supercomputers.
You're still, of course,
responsible for sharding
your data set,
distribute the data,
and all these kind of things.
So we ran on the Summit
supercomputer system.
So this is the number one
supercomputer in the world.
So there's this top 500 list,
which is updated twice a year.
So this is the system at Oak
Ridge National Laboratory.
It consists of 4,600 nodes.
It has two Power CPUs in
them and six Nvidia V100
GPUs with Tensor Cores.
They are connected using his
high speed NVLink interconnect,
which is very nice.
So we can do all
reductions within the node
very efficiently.
And it also features
800 gigabyte
of nonvolatile memory per note,
which is quite cool because you
can stage part of your
data set into that
and read it almost
with a DRAM speed.
So it's almost as fast as
reading it from main memory,
but it's much bigger.
So the network is pretty
fast and low latency.
And what I want
to point out here,
though, is that we talk a lot
about exascale computing, so
capability of 10 to the 18
floating point operations
per second in double precision.
So this is the next
generation of systems
want to deploy or
develop and deploy.
But really look at it.
If you can stick
with half precision,
so if you can basically
have an application which
can utilize half
precision almost for most
of the computations, you have
an exascale system available
right now.
So it's there.
It's in Oak Ridge.
You can just go and use it.
So there are some performance
optimizations necessary,
of course.
So when you think
about deep learning,
you have to optimize the
whole pipeline, right?
Starting from like the data--
where do you read it from?
Where to stage it in?
Then how do you feed it
efficiently to accelerator,
right?
The accelerator is
so fast that you
need to feed them
efficiently that they don't
stall waiting for that data.
For the computational
part, you want
to minimize the data
organization, for example.
And the reductions also need
to be very efficient, right?
Because you want to reduce
the gradients at a very, very
high frequency.
One thing we also use
was some overlapping
or grading pipelining
or asynchronous
approach you call it where you
do not reduce the gradients--
they do not compute
the fresh gradients
and produce them and
then integrate them.
But instead, you
come on the GPU.
You compute fresh gradients.
And then on the CPU, you
read all to the gradients
from the last step
from a buffer.
Reduce those asynchronously
to the competition
of the new gradients.
And integrate them
into the model.
So by that you can overlap
these two steps very nicely.
So this is a plot for
the performance we got.
So you see, the throughput
metric of images per second,
or call it samples per second,
versus the number of GPUs,
if you divide it by 6, you
get the number of nodes.
And the other
y-axis is basically
a translation of this
image throughput metric
into a more HPC
metric of petaflops
per second-- so 10 to the
15 operations per second.
So what you see is the FP32.
So the single precision
points are blues.
So I don't want to
talk about these.
What you can see that the
FP16, so the half precision
performance much,
much better, right?
So the Tensor Cores
can, in theory,
deliver 125 teraflops per card.
And that is what you see is
vast performance difference.
The dashed line
represents the ideal case.
in the ideal case,
where you don't
have any lost due
to communication,
you would be basically
on this line.
So we are a bit below with
the solid red line but not
far things.
I think it's
70-something percent, 79%
scanning efficiency.
And also what you see
that the lacked version--
so where you can
basically overlap
the computation of the
communication very nicely--
it's very crucial
to do this here
because the GPUs are so
fast that they really
need to wait for it
or reduce otherwise.
So and after we saw
this, we thought, OK, we
can go to a couple more nodes.
But we might not still
hit the exaflop mark,
which is this 1,000
petaflops per second.
So we restructured the
decoder a little bit,
and not like from
the predictive power.
But we removed some additional
data transpositions.
And we ran it on a
couple of more nodes
and actually got there.
So the performance number
we got at that scale
was 1.13 exaflops in FP16.
So half precision on 27,360 GPU.
And that is so far the biggest
deep learning calculation
I'm aware of.
So this is the training loss.
This is on a
slightly lower scale.
We don't have this full
history for the big scale.
However, what you can see--
the case I to make here is
that the select version,
although it's
partially asynchronous,
but it's like predictable
asynchronous in a way
that the network at the
beginning is a bit unstable.
So basically the training
[INAUDIBLE] grows.
So it oscillates heavily.
But then when you
just wait long enough,
it will outperform
the unlagged version.
So that, of course,
is not true for
every arbitrary like
deep learning network.
But for us, it's
definitely true.
And I think it's
definitely worth
a try if you have a
problem like that.
So talking about the results,
I have a video for this.
So on the left-hand side,
you see the predicted weather
patterns by the model.
In the right-hand side,
you see the ground truth.
So I have three things to say.
So first, there's some
qualitative agreement and also
quantitative agreement,
which is satisfactory.
What you also see is
that there are more
predicted events than
actually in the labels.
And that is mainly because
the aggressive thresholding,
sometimes forgets
to label stuff.
So when you maybe show
some of these samples
where we overpredict
atmospheric rivers, for example,
to experts, they say, yes.
Actually, the model picked up an
atmospheric river which was not
present in the ground truth.
And then you can also see
that the ground truth,
you see the video is flickering.
And this is because--
there's like a frame before and
after where it, for example,
picked up an atmospheric
river but a frame
in between where it did not.
But of course, it
should be continuous.
It should not be like this.
So the model actually
predicts something
which is much more continuous
and much more smooth.
Even if it did not--
the temporal dependence
into account.
So that is quite interesting.
So my conclusions are--
so TensorFlow is one of
the first applications
which reached exascale
performance, although only
in FP16.
But still it's remarkable.
And I think this is a
community achievement.
And HPC systems are suitable
for these workloads.
Of course, there are
some insufficiencies--
for example, the file system.
So we needed this large,
[INAUDIBLE] storage in order
to feed the data efficiently.
If you try to read from a
distributed file system,
it's very bad because HPC
file systems are optimized
for writing large chunks of data
but not doing random reads, OK?
So if you want to design HPC
system in the future, which
is very suitable
for deep learning,
you need to take
this into account.
So this is also
a very important.
And also, we want to
talk to storage people
to help us to develop better
distributed storage which
can cope with these
workflows better.
This work was awarded
the ACM Gordon Bell
prize at the last
supercomputing conference.
This price usually awarded for
an interesting and challenging
science problem for which you
need massive amounts of compute
to solve it.
And then you can show
that you actually
use this massive
amount of compute
efficiently to solve it.
So this is the paper link.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]